saludos en directo América de France 24
y me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
sala Mara bienvenida muy buena mañana de
jueves hoy lo vemos hoy volvemos a
responder las preguntas de la audiencia
esta vez alrededor de las vacunas del 19
tan polémicasmar buenos días Raúl
efectivamente aprovechamos para recordar
que con el hashtag salud f24 pueden
enviar sus dudas nosotros las trataremos
de responder aquí Hoy estamos hablando
de una pregunta de una usuaria de
Twitter que nos preguntó por el derecho
a saber los ingredientes de las vacunas
algo que ha surgido repetidas veces
desde que empezó la pandemia pues sobre
todo alrededor de las dudas sobre su
seguridad sobre si es bueno ponerse la
vacuna o no alguna preocupación Pues que
entendemos porque todo esto ha sido muy
nuevo para muchos de todos nosotros
empezamos con esta parte de la pregunta
que pregunta sobre el derecho a saber
los componentes de las vacunas no los
ingredientes de las vacunas no solo del
Kobe 19 sino de cualquier enfermedad son
públicos se encuentran con bastante
facilidad en línea en las agencias
regulatorias de los medicamentos por
ejemplo nosotros lo encontramos en la
fda en la página web de la fda de
Estados Unidos y por qué Pues porque las
patentes de las vacunas protegen estos
fármacos por ejemplo toda la información
alrededor del proceso de producción las
dosis de estos ingredientes la fórmula
no digamos el procedimiento pero no los
ingredientes en Sí porque además es una
información que debe saberse Por ejemplo
por motivos de alergias entre todo entre
otros no hay muchas vacunas por ejemplo
que llevan proteína de huevo y la gente
que es alérgica al huevo pues no se las
puedes poner Este no es el caso de las
vacunas contra el covid 19 claro digamos
mar es como una torta uno sabe la receta
que lleva huevo harina y azúcar pero
pues ya está en cada tienda que vende
las tortas cómo hacerla que echarle más
la proporción la dosis para que sea más
rica la torta exactamente
Entonces los ingredientes de esas
vacunas del covidísimo de también una
aclaración rapi importante que pongan el
hashtag de salud f24 para poder
filtrarlo no ante todos los comentarios
que nos llegan exactamente Raúl Muchas
gracias por la por la aclaración Vamos a
repasar dos ejemplos de la vacuna contra
el 19 precisamente esos ingredientes de
la torta de janssen Y defizer en este
caso empezamos por las de siempre el
primer elemento que tienen en este caso
es este vector recomendante de aire 26
eso es una de novillos eso son tipos de
virus que sirve como contenedor no es el
virus real sino como su estructura es
una envoltorio el transporte de luego
una proteína del virus del Kobe 19 que
va a servir como tarjeta de identidad
para que el cuerpo lo reconozcas es el
primer ingrediente el resto en general
por ejemplo son ingredientes como sales
o azúcares también Algún ácido etanol
que por ejemplo es un tipo de alcohol
que lo que sirven es pues para preservar
la vacuna para estabilizarla durante
todo el proceso de distribución y de
almacenamiento en el caso de las vacunas
por ejemplo producidas por pfizer y
bayon Tech en este caso son ARN
mensajero por lo tanto este factor
inmunizante es diferente en este caso
los las vacunas de mrn mensajero tienen
una pequeña dosis de material genético
que se introduce en el cuerpo para
despertar la respuesta inmune Cómo se
contiene este material genético Pues
también está en la lista de ingredientes
todos estos que vemos digamos en el
rango medio son un tipo de lípidos de
grasas que es lo que hace como este
contenedor del material genético para
que pueda entrar al cuerpo por ejemplo
el colesterol en este caso de origen
vegetal que sirve precisamente para este
propósito y todo lo de abajo se parece
mucho también en este caso a las vacunas
de janssen también son sales también son
pues por ejemplo la sacarosa que es
azúcar lo que consideramos azúcar de
mesa lo que consumimos que de nuevo
sirve pues para estabilizar para poder
mantener en buen estado esta vacuna en
general Más allá de las del covid 19
todos tienen Estos factores no un factor
inmunizante Y luego el resto que sirve
para para mantener para estabilizar la
vacuna recordamos que de nuevo le hemos
puesto el ejemplo de las vacunas del 19
Pero todas los ingredientes por ejemplo
la de la hepatitis b también se
encuentran fácilmente en línea me
encanta todo lo que contiene Entonces
esta vacuna pues importante saberlo yo
creo que esta Crónica le va a gustar a
muchísimas personas más hablemos de la
viruela del mono pasamos del covid a la
viruela Organización Mundial de la Salud
actualizó la situación y en qué estamos
sí Raúl Pues hay un nuevo parte
epidemiológico cada semana Normalmente
se actualiza La información entonces
aprovechamos para traer la colación de
nuevo a la espera además precisamente de
que hoy se reúne el comité asesor de la
OMS que decidirá si esto se trata de
nuevo de una emergencia de salud pública
o no escuchamos lo que decía la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
casi 14.000 casos confirmados se han
reportado a la OMS este año en más de 70
países y territorios hasta ahora se han
registrado cinco muertes solo en África
en África
moscaces continue to be reported from
europe la mayoría de los casos siguen
llegando desde Europa principalmente de
hombres que tienen sexo con hombres
Aunque vemos un declive en algunos
países en otros vemos un incremento
es importante también recordar que se
están contando desde mediados de junio
los casos juntamente de los países donde
la enfermedades endémica y los países
donde el brote es nuevo todo esto pues
para proyectar que en realidad es la
misma crisis sanitaria que nos afecta a
todos qué se está haciendo mal para
frenar este brote de la Aurora del mono
monkey pops en inglés sí Pues digamos
que además de información de
difuminación de diseminar toda esta
información de prevención también de
cómo evitar el contagio que hacer cuando
se contagias está intentando vacunar a
los grupos de riesgo que recordemos en
este caso sobre todo en los países donde
el brote es nuevo siguen siendo con una
amplia mayoría los hombres que tienen
relaciones sexuales con hombres hombres
gay bisexuales en general siguen siendo
la gran mayoría de los casos de contagio
que se reportan entonces en Estados
Unidos y en Europa se está empezando a
inmunizar estos grupos de riesgo con una
vacuna de la farmacéutica danesa
bavarian nortek que tiene una vacuna
contra la viruela no contra la viruela
del mono pero que se cree que igual
ofrece hace falta protección contra la
viruela del mono en este caso la
comisión europea compró ya más de
100.000 dosis que nos está distribuyendo
entre los países miembros de la Unión
Europea lo mismo está ocurriendo en
Estados Unidos y aún así hay escasez
Pues porque no estamos acostumbrados a
necesitar esta vacuna Entonces el ritmo
de producción Está muy bajo y vuelve el
debate de siempre no en los países donde
la enfermedad es endémica no está
llegando a la vacuna en los países que
tienen capacidad de compra Sí el dinero
mar Muchísimas gracias como siempre por
toda la información de salud mañana
volvemos por supuesto con más y pasamos
a saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día